foreign
[Music]
I've watched this two times in a row now
I feel like
it's such a fascinating foam I grew up
with
uh Tanya Tucker's music and
um you know I was born in the 70s group
in the 80s so
it's so funny I was trying to think like
other you know like what her women
contemporaries or who they were and you
show them Barbara Mandrell and Anne
Murray and it Stood Still I had albums
by all of these people
um
uh country you know I grew up in
Southern Illinois country music was was
and probably is still more popular than
pop
and
um so this was the soundtrack of my life
and it was amazing because I really
didn't know anything about her I really
didn't know much at all
in this
um so talk about uh had you worked with
Brandi Carlile before talk about
um
um had you made music video with her I
think I saw on your credits yeah and I
can also with that explain how this film
came about because that that's the
reason we had
I'd known her for many years through
other friends and other band Indigo
Girls
um and and so through the course of time
she supported a documentary that we did
through her foundation uh based on a
women's prison in Washington state
called the if project and she would go
there and play
on holiday like at Christmas play inside
for the women and so I did a piece for
her foundation following her and and her
time inside wccw and then another the
music video so kind of the social
justice oriented pieces music video for
hold out your hand
um and then some other pieces put
together for things that she did so we
had some creative Partnerships in the
past and so when this came about I got a
text from her wife that said you want to
hear something crazy
and so I thought about it was like do I
um I think I do
um and so we got on the phone and Brandi
told me that she had this opportunity to
produce this record with Tanya Shooter
Jennings had brought her into the
project
um and so of course it was like Danny
had to make a record in 20 years and
they were gonna go in the studio and she
knew that I was likely a fan which I was
grew up in the south
um and so I said of course I'm in hell
yes when do we start and she said
tomorrow
because this is often what happens
there's great with her it's like great
ideas not a lot of time and so luckily
my DP Jessica young was available so I
said give me an hour I'll call you back
and we'll make this happen which we did
and that's the
always answer a text from Brandy
Carlisle's wife is the lesson or
something yeah
I will never ignore a text from Brandon
Carlos wife again
um
so
this is uh was this where that was the
record all recorded because I noticed
you're at Sunset sound on Sunset was it
was it all recorded in Los Angeles yep
and that was the you know they'd never
met each other before this they and
there was we were all wondering if Tanya
was even gonna show up so there was a
lot of wondering about it Tandy didn't
really want to do it as I think you
sensed the trepidation through the
process
um but it was at Sunset nine days at
Sunset sound we filmed and then
continued on for the year after that so
it was like January 2019. so the whole
album was done in nine days yep wow yeah
is that usual for an album to get done
that fast I don't think so I think
honestly for part of that was a matter
of budget as a matter of timing
um and but what they got in the can was
incredible like by day two
from what I had heard and seen them
number one I went around and said like I
need to keep filming this like and also
this is going to win a Grammy like it's
not a it was an undeniable
what was happening in that studio was
amazing and I hope the Hope was to to
put that through on film and make it as
exciting as it was for us being there
but it was it was fast but I think
there's like I think more like two weeks
is kind of normal and sometimes dipping
back in but
they they made it happen in a very short
period of time
later scenes she would like to have gone
back to the studio as you saw
Tanya would like to redo everything
about this including this film
I'll read you the text that she sends me
um so yeah she's she's not really to be
clear she loves the film but there are
moments that she's like I don't know
yeah I was in the bathroom when that
part happened I don't remember that yeah
I mean we we would all like to go back
fix things about everything that we do
right
um
she so yeah she's she's got a lot of
nerves about doing this and we see you
know um Brandy has to really kind of
like you know talk her through this like
it sounds great you're doing great
was it hard to talk Tanya into doing the
film of her making this album no weirdly
it was easy and she talked about this
like we hadn't actually really even
talked about this process until we were
in Toronto together
and
she's been filmed so much of her life so
for her as a kid being filmed she had a
reality TV show so having a camera on
wasn't unusual for her and she's very
comfortable in front of the camera
and at some point she turned around to
us and said I think this is we were in
Nashville filming in her house
and she turned around to somebody and
said knowing we were listening and said
I don't do anything unless it's on
camera you know so she enjoys the
process for sure but I think there's the
fun stuff that she had been a part of
and then there's a level of
vulnerability that was also present
particularly in the studio that was
extremely courageous for her to allow
like never once did she say stop filming
she also has a guy that travels around
with her and just films stuff in general
so it wasn't like
she's stepping into the spotlight again
in that way she has this is this wasn't
an unusual process but was what was
unusual was recording in the way that
she did and and
20 years ago when she did a record it
was all on tape and it wasn't this vocal
comp over and over stop and start patch
things together she was like do it all
in one take right and so for her to
allow that to be seen and she's a
perfectionist I think as you can see in
the film that was to me my fear when she
saw this movie of everything that she
was gonna not want that to be shown like
Yeah because it was hard for her and a
lot of ways making that record she'd
lost her parents she was stepping into
something new and so but she's like you
know people need to see that people need
to learn from this kind of courage
so you know she's
it was amazing how simple it was
actually right truly well I just felt
both her and Brandi were making
themselves completely I mean everybody
working on that record was making
themselves completely vulnerable and
allowing that to be filmed because a lot
of of uh artists wouldn't want you to
see their creative process they wouldn't
want you to see their bad takes or you
know they wouldn't want you to see what
it actually
takes to get to the good take all the
bad takes that it takes to get to the
kids yeah and that's what makes this
film interesting I think and it also
makes them special people is that you
know Brandi believes in sort of radical
truth telling and Tanya is just someone
who is herself a hundred percent of the
time and so neither one of them had
anything to say about that at all it was
like you do the thing that you do
and we'll see it and have conversations
about it but there was never any
pushback in any way I think it was just
like the joy to see that process and for
people to learn from it and understand
like what it really takes
to to you know the creative process is
hard
it never occurred so I never thought of
Tanya Tucker before as a child star but
when she was telling shooter and Brandy
the story about how she really
didn't really enjoy very many of her
performances at all it reminded me of
that scene in the movie Judy about Judy
Garland where she was talking about in
you know when she quit MGM or she got
fired from MGM and she started doing the
series of live concerts that that she
did and then she really got to
sing for herself she she actually got to
and start to enjoy performing when she
never had before because she was forced
to right like since the age of 13. and
so I was sort of thinking of Tanya that
way you know like a lot of child stars
someone discovers that you can do
something amazing so this sort of push
you to the top without any thought about
whether you actually enjoyed doing that
or not yeah and I think that part of
I think Tanya once she gets on stage she
loves it and she loves her fans and she
loves the commuting with the audience
and the joy of making music but I think
it's all the pressure that surrounds it
because it you know she's for 50 years
she's been working you know and I know
that she's enjoyed a lot of that but it
is there was a lot of pressure on her to
make money for the family and then once
you do to keep doing that
and and I you see some of her Diaries in
there and there's a diary she kept that
I have you know that part of it is in
the film but she writes about that and
it's from her record deal being signed
at 16 up through like 17 or 18 which is
the real Heyday like she beats Elvis her
hero and Elvis died like in this window
of time so much went on for her in a lot
of ways so I think there's the balance
of the joy and then the pressure and
she's a perfectionist and a lot of it is
live performing her band's Never Getting
It Right and and so once she can let
that go then she can enjoy it but it is
I think it's still a constant cycle
today even like I think being traveling
with the film and talking about herself
like it's a lot of that not wanting the
attention on herself she's happy to put
it on somebody else right and that's
just the cycle of who she is I mean her
whole entire family being on her payroll
that's a parallel with Elvis as well and
it's really it makes all your
relationships so complicated
um it explains a lot about her
complicated relationship with her dad
um because he was the person that made
her a success but also
kind of took away her child to you know
she wasn't a child anymore she was at 13
she was a working adult yeah and I think
she she looks back on it with happy
memories but also
you know you see in the in the film that
footage that was shot of her at the time
that's like you know this is tiring I am
a kid but this is a lot of work
but uh you know I I also think that he
was that steady Force for her and that's
the reason that she didn't make music
for nearly 20 years was not having that
guiding post that guide post that
brought things forward and I think
Brandy presented that strength for her
that no one had prior that made her feel
comfortable enough to step into the
space and to move forward which was
interesting you know and because they
have a lot of similarities in their
background and Grant Brandy grew up poor
and
horses like there was so much that's
very much the same and and her able to
give that strength and that place for
Tanya in a positive way moving forward
hopefully was you know a healing cycle
in some ways for her so interestingly
this past year in July
um up popped this viral video of Brandy
Carlisle
and Joni Mitchell at the Newport Folk
Festival in basically
Brandy had done the same thing with Joni
Mitchell she had pulled
a legendary singer and a wreck a
pre-reclusive person out
to do her first performance in years so
what is it about Brandy who's so
interested in doing this with like
female musicians like helping them find
Their audience again
I think she's
she was actually doing those Joni jams
when she called about the Tanya thing
like that was happening
for many many years
um and she told me and I was like can I
film that she's like I was over at
Joni's and Chaka Khan rolls in smoking a
cigarette singing and Herbie Hancock's
on the piano I was like so could when
can I go after we do the 10 thing can we
go do that
um but I think she's very interested in
as with Tanya it's like what forms us
and why and for her as an artist you
know looking at these elements of kind
of the patchwork of who she is and Tanya
gave her her toughness and a lot of what
she does with her does with her voice
and she didn't know about Joni actually
until much much later in life her her
wife introduced her to Joni who is now I
can see the Joni influences in her like
you and me on the Rock on her most
recent record
but I think she's very interested in the
not just the history of music but what
forms us and shapes us and what our
influences are and we also live in a
culture where particularly among women
that you know when you get old you're
supposed to disappear and go away and if
you're a man and older in this business
you're celebrated in a different kind of
way and I think that Brandy's very
interested in paying attention to these
folks who she's seen that happen and
some by choice and Joni's case you know
and and Tanya sort of by choice but she
was kind of marginalized all along
and she you know similarly may have a
Staples like she's been working with a
lot of these artists that we we should
always be paying attention and listening
to and women have a different journey in
the business so I can't speak for her
but I can you know in the observations
of what she's done I you know that it's
that we can't lose these folks and pay
attention to them while we have them and
celebrate them can't you do Barbara
Mandrell next
I'll see if I I'll find out I mean I
need an updated version of sleeping
single in a double bed
a good one I hope Barbara's gonna be
gonna be a reference of her in this film
but we'll see
she looks great agreed
um
yeah I would love it if she could do all
the 80s country music star Barbara
Crystal Gayle yeah yeah
I mean and we also may take a moment to
uh I think for uh recognition of the
loss of Loretta Lynn
and
Tanya's relationship with that speaking
of the contemporaries and the other
folks but you know she
I'm I was glad to have
the really that's the friendship that
Tanya has with Brandi that's formed and
then the next generational friendship is
you know of Tanya and Loretta which is a
real true deep incredible friendship and
to have that
captured on film
like I'm you know I'm glad that we have
that living for folks to see and pay
attention to because their friendship is
pretty extraordinary and
Loretta and her family are the reasons
why we got to uh we were allowed to film
at the Bridgestone Arena at that show
because it was nobody else was allowed
but us and it was because you know ready
said you know if you're with Tanya
you're with us and you can film
so you know that's so there's no footage
of that show except for what you were
able to film they filmed in terms of
behind the scenes stuff they filmed it
but it was never released they filmed it
that night just captured it and I I'm
wondering if they're gonna release it
now at this point but yeah
so what um what is next for you
can you can you talk about is the top
secret Angela's like nothing
that's my girl
investor and girlfriend up there nothing
I'm actually producing a documentary on
the Indigo Girls
um so that will be that's insane yeah
I'm very excited yeah so that's
happening now that's hopefully you'll be
seeing that at the beginning of next
year at some point or we have some Great
Cuts that have we've just completed
um and then yeah I've got other projects
that I began before this one
um then I'm going getting back to to
complete and then you know maybe taking
a nap I guess that's good take a rest
yeah
uh as a lesbian I have to say thank you
so much for doing a tribute to the
interview girls
look the most important band of my life
it's pretty amazing I have to say like
deep deep uh and like very in very
personal very in depth with who they are
and why I mean I think we'll make the
lesbians proud
okay
and that's you know straight however you
identify I hope everyone when you
straight people too but I'm just things
um I saw the Menthol illness Fair it's a
deeply ingrained
[Laughter]
um so when does this come out
so this will be theatrically released uh
October 22nd so coming up soon there's
actually I think some special screenings
on the 20th but New York and La uh the
weekend of the 21st and then Nationwide
after that
are you and um
you and Tanya and um Brandi doing a
press tour we are well there's a day in
New York I leave tomorrow morning and go
do a bunch of stuff and then we end up
in New York and so we've got some press
tours bringing them together is not an
easy thing so we've got them together
for a day to run around the city and
drink some tequila and of course do the
Today show with ruby red grapefruits yes
that's right
all right well thank you so much for
coming to talk and thank you for this
film it was so wonderful thank you for
having us thank you all of you
thanks y'all
[Music]